my guess this week for the new revamped
relaunched fan funded Reuben report is a
comedy legend an activist and author an
actress and entrepreneur and a former
presidential candidate roseanne plus
mother and grandmother don't forget the
most important part I should have done
those two first right but you know
that's how you are that's okay I've made
the correction alright let's jump right
into your third there that's so rad
there's B you told me once I loved her
that you loved her but you also told me
that you thought that the gay community
rallied behind the Golden Girls in a
weird way that they didn't quite behind
you even though you were actually doing
a lot more Pro gay stuff because you did
the first gay kiss which we'll talk
about later and all that stuff is that a
weird thing because it was sort of like
the Conners were sort of the reverse of
what people think of as gay is
over-the-top and flamboyant and the
Conners were working-class that's not
thought of as yeah some some working
class people are games there are they
are some up a market they're not a Bravo
though well they're gonna they're right
next to Bravo on TLC like the duck
dynasty I mean you know come on those
guys there's a lot of gays in that
family yeah but I don't know they they
looked really gay at first I saw it on
the internet and they were like in these
golf shirts and [ __ ] and they were all
clean-shaven Republicans right which
kind of means gay right
and then they grew the beards to get the
show and and I think they did have the
southern accents but I watch that show
the other day I think it's cry I'm
transfixed why these reality shows are
very good you had your own reality show
I had two or three of them what was it
see at Roseanne's nuts which I loved
there were more bleep you had more
bleeps per minute than anything I've
ever seen I would say that I was
difficult you know that's how I talk
they want to see the real me I mean if
they didn't want to see the real me I
could never figure out well why don't
you go higher
you know Raquel Welch or somebody write
that right you don't want to see me
I saw one episode you were on like a
truck and you were like plowing through
the macadamia things and you were
clearing brush and I'm getting my
aggression out yeah
and killing a you know non-indigenous
what do you call it colonial growth my
pure Pele nest so you had so the
macadamia stuff that is indigenous - no
it's not it's from New Zealand really
the max eat the Big Island Hawaii where
I lived that was the world's lab
laboratory where all those people went
and they did experiments in the earth of
what would grow you know and so those
macadamia nuts they're not indigenous
really they they are from New Zealand
and they were brought over at the very
same time when the pineapple which is
not indigenous to the Big Island of
Hawaii was brought there too so they
were manufacturing this perfect
cyborg biosphere right and and they have
been since the late 1800s on the Big
Island you're blowing my mind or yours
was a [ __ ] farmer but macadamia nuts
and pineapples are neither indigenous to
Hawaii no not the kind they brought over
huh they brought in a pineapple from
other Hawaiian Islands and then they
brought the papaya and the mango and
they totally GMO manufactured the papaya
that's why you know that's why I end up
running for president because I was part
of kickin yeah Monsanto's ass off the
Big Island Hawaii and we did win and we
did kick Monsanto out and I I was so
proud of that because I all time I be
like you know I'm meditating stuff so
I'd be like what would be the best words
I always meditate for the right words
cuz I'm a comic that's what we do we're
always looking forward
mm-hmm that fit and whatever I very
seldom brag about myself and my writing
and stuff or maybe I do it too much
my dreams I passed well you do have 18
cups here I'm not sure what's going on
here water coffee and my specialty the
specialties yeah for my boys yeah yeah
we'll keep that one quiet
remember Jackie Gleason that was my
favorite thing I know it has a little
girl yeah he'd take that drinker and
Jack Paar too they act like they're
drinking you knew it was you just looked
for how where the you knew it was
because I did that bit so many times
people used to be able to drink on
television no people here would be
smoking I mean Johnny Carson was smoking
cigarettes and they were drinking and
having a good time and now everything's
where they couldn't swear we can say
whatever you want you want to throw an
f-bomb right now just for just an extra
one no because that kicks in my OCD oh
so if we vote if we throw one and it
could unfurl though it will it will it's
like don't even go there it's like that
first drink
you know I go to Alcoholics I think you
just blew a joke that you should write
that down get that down [ __ ] pan I
never have [ __ ] pan while your thing
isn't that what do you want to say I
feel like I'm in therapy because I Bea
Arthur about be in the gays [ __ ]
great
yeah so but being the guy isn't he gay I
don't know I don't know either
I saw her sing this song to her husband
on Broadway because I want to see L saw
her play oh I saw the play yeah yeah
what's not great it was wonderful it was
wonderful it's all like old all her old
stories and what it was like to be
trapped in that little TV box which you
know you know all about I just like her
boy so much everybody thinks that that's
what'll be miss of that boys yeah it was
such a genius once in a lifetime boys
and when she sang it was so beautiful
yeah but it was her boys singing and boy
she was a master of that Wow
few people are what do you think about
that that idea of that the the gays
rallied around the Golden Girls in a way
that they maybe didn't around Roseanne
but you did I mean that kiss I remember
watching that kiss whatever year that
was maybe 97 or something and it was not
really
and bars all over America yes we were
trying there wasn't technology then but
we were trying to hook up phone calls to
like it central but now of course it all
be you know I don't know what they do
now yeah
bouncing off Mars or something with my
no it's involved with my recent
technological now yeah so I wish I was
working then when it was high tech like
that well you're working right now well
in my own studio you know I just got on
this kit cuz I have really bad OCD but I
just wanted to know what does it feel
like to own your own work and just like
say what you want to say and be who you
really are it it takes a lot of
sacrifice man yeah I mean we have been
working out the ass every day we have
been I've never worked harder in my life
than we've worked in these last couple
months as we've put this thing together
well you gotta work hard yeah you gotta
pay the [ __ ] cost to be the [ __ ]
boss I ain't no [ __ ] yeah you own
the sitcom no you didn't own it
I own a percentage of it right that
makes me you know I could go like I do
get depressed over that I own 20% of my
own work mm-hmm
and I put I'm the one that put my life
on the line
that would certainly won any committee
involved there but every joke there was
a [ __ ] committee involved but at the
final hour I just say what I want in
front of the camera and let the audience
decide if I got a bigger laugh than all
them writers then we kept that yeah and
if they got a bigger laugh than me we
kept that I mean I cared about the
product yeah and I sigh for all the
other names they call me cotton [ __ ]
and all that [ __ ] cuz you know whatever
you know it's important that an artist
control his or her own wife and product
and everything I mean that reaction
ain't free for somebody to take isn't it
cool that we're cutting out the
network's now in a way because look I
mean we lie thanks oh yeah like I own
this thing I have no I don't have to
answer it any you know you're gonna work
[ __ ] hard yeah you're not no [ __ ]
Democrat
you